guy qui a présidé nos travaux pour son
efficacité
et
sa parfaite organisation remercie aussi
des habitants de rome pour leur accueil
si chaleureux à l'occasion de ce g20
rien n'était écrit d'avancé je crois
pouvoir dire ce g20 a témoigné de son
utilité malgré une sortie du coc vide
qui rendait une partie des débats
difficiles avec plusieurs de nos
collègues à distance malgré le contexte
que nous connaissons et beaucoup de deux
divisions de diversion qui étaient là
ce g20 a permis véritablement d'obtenir
des résultats et de marquer une étape je
crois structurante dans ce que j'ai
voulu défendre est souvent appelée ce
multilatéralisme efficace
premièrement sur le coeur du métier du
g20 à savoir la relance de l'économie
mondiale dans le contexte que nous
connaissons et une relance juste
plusieurs résultats ont été obtenus par
ce g20 nous allons d'abord
converger et tous sur la nécessité
d'avoir une coordination étroite entre
pays producteurs et consommateurs sur
les sujets d'énergie par le consensus
s'est établi sur le fait que à la fois
la forte augmentation mais aussi la
volatilité des prix qu'il s'agisse
du gaz comme du pétrole est de nature
aujourd'hui à fragiliser la reprise et
la croissance mondiale et donc
il a été acté une nécessité de se
coordonner entre états producteurs et en
attaque entre étape consommateurs à très
court terme c'est un élément clé
aujourd'hui pour éviter toute tension
excessive c'est la même chose que nous
avons aussi acté sur plusieurs
composants particulier dans le secteur
industriel nous y travaillons ardemment
en plus de ces initiatives il ya
évidemment tout ce que nous faisons au
niveau européen et au niveau national
deuxième élément et c'est pour moi l'un
des résultats les plus structurants de
ce g20 nous avons confirmé l'accord qui
avait été obtenu au niveau des ministres
des finances sur la fiscalité en effet
c'est un résultat historique celui qui
permet une taxation juste 15% à minima
des multinationales et des grandes
plateformes du numérique ce qui pour nos
concitoyens était une attente forte et
ici je tiens vraiment à souligner ce
résultat très concret d'abord parce
qu'il est le fruit d'un travail et d'un
combat que la france mène depuis quatre
ans d'un combat qui nous a parfois valu
des rétorsions je pense en particulier
aux viticulteurs français qui ont eu à
subir l'ire de la précédente
administration américaine et subir des
mesures de rétorsion à cause de ce soir
est donc là où nous avions d'abord voulu
bâtir un accord européen où il nous
avait été opposé la nécessité d'un
accord au niveau de l' ocde cet accord
est maintenant obtenu le g20 l'a endossé
ce qui nous permettra sur le premier
pilier de le traduire concrètement par
une convention ocde en janvier pardon
durant l'année 22 et une mise en oeuvre
à partir du 1er janvier 2023 et sur le
2e pilier une directive européenne qui
sera soumise par la commission
européenne dans les prochaines semaines
et non feront tout pour qu'elle puisse
être parachevée sous la présidence
française et donc nous sommes bien au
temps des avancées du concret ce ne sont
plus des mots et des déclarations nous
avons réussi à convaincre tout le monde
est à bâtir un accord sur cette taxation
juste et minimale qui est à mes yeux un
très grand changement de la même manière
nos travaux ont aussi permis de venir à
bout de désaccords que nous avions sur
en particulier l'acier et l'aluminium et
de démanteler les tarifs qui avaient été
mises en place par les états unis
d'amérique sur l'europe ce qui est un
point important aussi de la pacification
des relations de l'amélioration du lien
transatlantique sur ce sujet enfin sur
le ce premier volet qui est celui de
l'économie mondiale ce g20 a permis de
mettre en oeuvre la aussi ce qui était
au coeur de l'agenda français pour une
reprise économique plus juste la
question d'une fine d'un financement
solidaire de la relance mondiale et de
la réallocation des droits de tirage
spéciaux vers les pays les plus pauvres
voire revenu intermédiaire et en
particulier les pays africains il y a un
an presque jour pour jour lors du forum
de paris pour la paix
la france avec
plusieurs autres états amis avaient avec
la directrice générale du fmi lancé
cette idée que nous puissions émettre
des droits de tirages spéciaux pour
pouvoir accroître le financement les
pays qui en avaient le plus besoin c'est
650 milliards cet accord s'est
cristallisée avec la nouvelle
administration américaine le 18 mai
dernier à paris alors que ses 650
milliards était confirmé nous avons
plaidé pour qu'il y ait une réallocation
des droits de tirage spéciaux permettant
d'atteindre 100 milliards de droits de
tirage spéciaux vers l'afrique parce que
la clé de répartition normal ne donner
qu'une vingtaine de milliards après
effort 33 milliards au continent
africain
là où nous étions il faut bien le dire
quelques rares à le demander au moins de
mai dernier le travail de ces derniers
mois a permis de consacrer aujourd'hui
un accord des pays du g20 pour qu'il y
ait plus de 100 milliards qu'ils aillent
vers l'afrique grâce à sa très haut le
réel aux questions la france a fixé les
talons à 20% de réallocation de nos
propres droits de tirage spéciaux ainsi
suivis par les américains les
britanniques les italiens et d'autres
pays qui se sont engagés à contribuer
c'est une avancée majeure parce qu'elle
est un élément contribution justement
financement des économies africaines
dans le contexte que nous connaissons je
rappelle que la banque mondiale a établi
le besoin de financement des économies
africaines de 2020 2025 environ 300
milliards de dollars nous faisons avec
cela le tiers de l'effort ce n'est donc
pas pour solde de tout compte mais c'est
une contribution essentielle dans un
paysage où nous n'étions pas au rendez
vous des résultats
je tiens à dire ici que cette
réallocation nos droits de tirage
spéciaux est additionnel et
supplémentaires à tout ce qui est fait
par ailleurs en matière climatique
la deuxième grande priorité pour moi le
sujet d'avancé de ce g20 est en matière
de santé nous savons que seule la
coopération permet de vaincre
véritablement la pandémie et donc nous
avons consolidé plusieurs heures
d'avancé lors de ce g20 d'accord d'abord
par un accord pour que les états
partagent de manière transparente les
informations sur le partage et la
livraison de doses la france plaide
depuis plusieurs mois vous le savez pour
que nous ayons avant tout nous
concentrions sur le nombre de doses
livrets sont juste suivi en fonction des
besoins
et ne pas substituer ce débat par
l'accumulation de milliards dont on ne
connaît pas ni le rythme ni finalité
c'est nécessaire pour tenir nos
objectifs de vaccination à l'échelle
internationale et surtout pour être au
rendez vous des besoins de nos
partenaires et qu'un sur ce volet le
gérant acté ce mécanisme de transparence
indispensable et je veux essayer de dire
que l'europe est exemplaire mais que la
france est au rendez vous de ces
objectifs qui ne sont donc pas là aussi
que des mots la france s'était engagée
je vous le rappelle il y a 6 mois a
donné 60 millions de doses j'avais
ensuite il ya quelques mois augmenter
cet engagement disons nous donnerons 60
millions de doses d'ici la fin de
l'année 2000 21 et 120 millions de doses
d'ici juin 2022 je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes au rendez
vous est même en avance sur ses
engagements puisque au moment où je vous
parle la france a donné aux mécanismes
kovacs 67 millions de doses ce qui
signifie que maintenant sept pour
certaines
qui ont 20 un peu plus de 20 millions
ces doses soissons ont déjà été
distribués et vaccinés soit sont en
cours d'acheminement pour tout le reste
c'est une discussion entre les
laboratoires et kovacs mais le transfert
si je puis dire de propriété a été acté
entre la france et le mécanisme covas 67
millions de doses et nous le
complèteront évidemment sur le début de
l'année 2022 pour être au rendez vous de
nos autres objectifs si tous les pays du
g20 font comme la france c'est à dire
que un habitant de une dose au mécanisme
kovacs alors nous serons en capacité de
tenir nos objectifs de vaccination pour
la fin de l'année 2021
deuxième élément clé en matière de lutte
contre la pandémie est évidemment la
levée des restrictions à l'export
en effet durant toute la crise nous
avons vu que des mécanismes de
restrictions à l'export avait ou bloquer
la production de certains états membres
ou bloquer la juste distribution vers
des pays en particulier des pays en voie
de développement ou à revenu
intermédiaire qui en avaient besoin à
cet égard je veux également rappelé la
fierté que nous pouvons avoir en tant
qu'européen l'europe est le seul
continent au monde qui n'a jamais
procédé à ces restrictions à l'export au
moment où je vous parle l'union
européenne a produit 2 milliards de elle
en a
produit la moitié pour elle-même et
exporter l'autre moitié aucun autre ne
peut plaider un tel bilan et donc il est
absolument important à cet égard de
continuer sur cette voie et de lutter
contre tous les mécanismes qui ont pu
entraver la bonne preuve la bonne
avancée de notre lutte contre l'épidémie
durant les mois précédents et en
particulier de renforcer le rôle de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce et
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé à
ce titre
troisième élément clé en matière de
vaccins c'est évidemment de poursuivre
notre impulsion pour aider à produire
davantage de vaccins dans les pays à
revenu intermédiaire et pays les plus
pauvres pour permettre une vaccination
plus rapide et plus efficace c'est
complémentaire c'est absolument
nécessaire ça ne se substitue pas parce
qu'on sait que même si on accélère cette
production elle prendra plusieurs mois
parfois plusieurs années elle ne peut
répondre à l'urgence de la politique
vaccinale sur le continent africain en
particulier
cette stratégie c'est celle que nous
avons lancé au printemps dernier au
rwanda et en afrique du sud
des déplacements que j avais effectué et
de manière très étroite avec plusieurs
états membres de l'union en particulier
l'allemagne mais avec également
évidemment la commission européenne et
beaucoup d'autres partenaires nous avons
d'ores et déjà avancé en signant des
contrats au rwanda en afrique du sud
mais également au sénégal lesquelles
impliquent d'ailleurs très étroitement
les instituts pasteur et plusieurs
autres entreprises européennes également
international je rappelle les chiffres
l'afrique
représente 20% des besoins de
vaccination pour cette pandémie comme
pour tout autre elle a aujourd'hui 2 %
des capacités de production ce qui veut
dire que face à une crise similaire nous
serions confrontés
évidemment aux mêmes problèmes
d'acheminement
tout ça plaide pour continuer à avancer
sur une meilleure coordination et nos
travaux ont permis aussi d'avancer dans
notre conduite on est notre volonté de
financer justement des mécanismes de
prévention et de suivi de telles crises
coordonner de manière très étroite et
sous supervision de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé ce qui est
absolument indispensable je veux aussi
rappeler l'importance d'avoir une
politique cohérente et dans la durée
pour renforcer les systèmes de soins
primaires des pays les plus pauvres en
particulier les pays africains ce que la
france conduit à travers son aide
bilatérale et le travail que fait
l'agencé française de développement et
ce que nous souhaitons renforcer en
particulier à travers nos partenariat
avec l'unicef parce que sans ce
justement c'est ce renforcement des
mécanismes de santé primaires les
campagnes de vaccination ne peuvent être
assurés sur le terrain même quand les
doses sont livrés
troisième priorité après la croissance
mondiale plus juste et la lutte contre
la pandémie c'est l'impulsion nécessaire
à la coop 26 qui s'ouvre est donc la
contribution en matière justement
climats et biodiversité
de ce g20
là dessus je veux le dire ce g20 a été
malgré les tensions malgré les
divergences qui peuvent apparaître et
qui les négociations des dernières jours
parfois des dernières heures ont pu
confirmer a permis de recréer de la
convergence en vue de glasgow ce qui
montre qu'il n'ya pas de fatalité et
qu'au contraire nous pouvons avoir des
résultats concrets
j'entends tous les discours très
alarmiste sur ces sujets je suis moi
même inquiet et nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés
mais je voudrais qu'on prenne deux pas
de recul et qu'on regarde la situation
nous étions il y a quatre ans il ya
quatre ans les états unis d'amérique
disait nous quittons l'accord de paris
la russie et la turquie avait toujours
pas ratifié ces accords et tout le monde
douté de nos capacités à être dans les
clous
au moment où je vous parle
l'union européenne
a pris toutes les décisions et
maintenant c'est une question de mise en
oeuvre pour être dans les clous
réhaussé nos engagements pour 2030 avoir
un green deal qui nous permet d'être au
rendez-vous de 2030 et endossé ensemble
en européen objectif de neutralité
carbone 2050 les etats unis sont revenus
dans le club et on ré adhérer aux
accords de paris et la russie et la
turquie ont ratifié cet accord
donc nous avons re converger malgré
toutes les difficultés le risque était
cette sortie de qu'ovide d'avoir un
doute et au fond une fracture nord-sud
qui se recréer sur le sujet des
financements et de la capacité a réussi
premièrement nous avons tous actes et ai
dit clairement que l'ambition d 1,5
degrés d'augmentation devait être
réitérée et donc tous ceux qui voulaient
oublier cet objectif sombré en quelque
sorte dans la fatalité des deux pots des
2 degrés
n'ont pas eu raison de nos débats ce qui
est en quelque sorte le premier élément
duquel on décline ensuite la neutralité
carbone 2050 le renforcement de nos
objectifs 2030 et place tous les pays
membres du g20 dans la même dynamique
maintenant tout le travail va être de
continuer à obtenir des efforts
supplémentaires de la chine d'autres
émergents et de la russie en particulier
pour pouvoir tenir cet agenda mais
d'ores et déjà les derniers mois et la
stratégie nationale que la chine a
annoncé d'ailleurs ces derniers jours
montrent que des pas continuer à être
fait dans la bonne direction
deuxième point la progression de ceux de
ce g20 c'est notre accord sur justement
le financement solidaire cette stratégie
clim les fameux 100 milliards et le
fonds de 100 milliards pour financer la
transition climatique et énergétique des
pays en voie de développement et des
pays les plus pauvres
sur ce sujet quelle est notre difficulté
notre difficulté a été la disparition
des états unis d'amérique pendant quatre
ans c'est ça la règle c'est que là où
nous avons accumulé des financements
durant plusieurs années qui permettent
d'être au rendez-vous pour 2020 il ya eu
un retard américain je veux saluer
vraiment le réengagement de
l'administration du président ben ali et
sa volonté de rattraper ce retard le
rapport remis par l' ocde
montre que nous arriverons au 100
milliards de finances climat en 2023 et
que nous atteindrons près de 600
milliards sur la période 2020 2025 ce
qui veut dire que oui nous serons au
rendez-vous des 100 milliards par an sur
2020 2025 on peut le dire à la lumière
de ce rapport et d engagement confirmé
deuxièmement la question clé c'est ce
que nous sommes dès maintenant à 100
milliards par an et les quelques
milliards qui nous manquent
sont dues à un effort additionnel qui
doit passer ou pas au congrès américain
sur ce sujet je veux dire très
clairement que là aussi l'europe est au
rendez-vous de ses engagements avec plus
de 25 milliards d'euros par an nous
sommes au rendez vous des engagements
que nous avions pris et nous irons plus
loin encore et la france est au
rendez-vous de ses engagements avec 7
milliards de dollars par an donc sur ce
point nous sommes véritablement
au rendez-vous de ce que nous devions
faire et des engagements que nous avions
ce que nous avons discuté entre états
membres et ce que nous avons discuté
avec le fmi et ce qui doit pour moi dans
les prochains jours être pas achevé
c'est de savoir comment mieux mobiliser
la solidarité internationale et nos
financements pour permettre de couvrir
l'écart éventuelles qu'il y aurait dès
l'année 2000 21 avec une réallocation
encore supplémentaire des droits de
tirage spéciaux ou un accord additionnel
du congrès conformément à ce que propose
l'administration américaine troisième
avancée en matière de climat c'est sur
le charbon le g20 comme vous le savez
réunit les plus grands émetteurs de la
planète
ensemble ils représentent 80% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre il
était donc très important qu'ils
s'engagent et nous avons pris ensemble
un engagement très concrets
que nous apporterons sur la table de la
coop celui d'arrêter tout financement
international du charbon à l'étranger
d'ici la fin de cette année et engager
la transition de toutes les économies du
g20 vers une énergie décarbonée là aussi
rien n'était écrit en la matière je veux
saluer les efforts faits dès le g7 par
la corée du sud et le japon et ces
dernières semaines par la chine qui ont
permis
c'est pour moi un élément clé de la
transformation
à celui
l'ensemble
si besoin était de donner un exemple à
cet égard l'afrique du sud suffit à
l'illustré elle est un exemple très
concret de ce que nous pouvons faire
l'afrique du sud à travers justement une
stratégie nationale très ambitieuse est
en train de finaliser un accord
permettant de réduire très fortement sa
dépendance au charbon et est accompagné
par l'allemagne la france le royaume-uni
les etats-unis la commission européenne
pour justement accompagner sa transition
et passer d'une économie très dépendante
du charbon à une économie décarbonée
au-delà de cet agenda très ambitieux en
matière de climat nous avons aussi acté
en g20 le lien extrêmement structurants
qui existe entre l'agenda climatique l
agenda pour la biodiversité
puisque nous aurons encore demain à
glasgow plusieurs éléments qui acteront
de celui ci et nous l'avons montré en
début d'année avec le one planet ce
mythe à paris mais cet agenda se
renforcent mutuellement la france comme
vous le savez a pris plusieurs
engagements réitérés à lui scène à
marseille il y a quelques mois et des
initiatives comme la grande muraille
verte acte la complémentarité de ces
deux agendas
enfin plus largement ce g20 a permis
également de revenir sur l'agenda
transatlantique j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer avec le président byden
vendredi après midi sur ce sujet qui
revenir ensuite d'avancé sur l'agenda
indo pacifique
je pourrais revenir si vous le souhaitez
dans le cadre des questions mais à
travers les différentes bilatérales que
j'ai pu mener avec l'indonésie l'inde la
corée du sud ou singapour nous avons là
aussi avancé sur notre vision et les
concrétisations qui sont les nôtres sur
l'agenda indo pacifique nous avons pu
aussi avancé sur l'agenda euro africain
puisque nous avons organisé hier en
marge de ce g20 une réunion entre
les principaux dirigeants africains
présents et quelques autres en
visioconférence et les dirigeants
européens présents pour bâtir l'agenda
est la substance de ce qui sera le
sommet entre l'union africaine et
l'union européenne qui se tiendra les 17
et 18 février prochain et ce sommet
était aussi l'occasion de plusieurs
échanges bilatéraux sur lequel je pense
que nous ne manquerons pas de revenir
dans le cadre des questions en
particulier avec nos amis et voisins
britanniques enfin je pense que ce g20
doit nous conduire à sortir également
plus fort en soutien à nos organisations
multilatérales je l'évoquais nous devons
dans le contexte qui est le nôtre
continuer de réactiver des travaux pour
la modernisation de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce et bâtir un agenda
commercial cohérent avec nos objectifs
climatiques et sociaux deuxièmement nous
devons absolument défendre
l'indépendance de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé mais sa place dans
la coordination de toutes les
initiatives prises en la matière
troisièmement renforcer le rôle de l'
ocde qui va avoir un rôle d'exécution
absolument clé dans la mise en oeuvre de
notre taxation minimale mais qui est
aussi un acteur clé de la politique de
responsabilité de suivi des résultats en
termes climatique ça a été un souhait de
la france est une initiative portée il
ya quelques mois et enfin une politique
de soutien aussi à l'égard de plusieurs
agences des nations unies comme le
programme alimentaire mondial puisque
nous aurons en la matière une initiative
que nous portons aussi pour lancer une
coalition justement pour l'alimentation
de nos enfants et en particulier la
bonne alimentation à l'école de nos
enfants qui est clé dans compte tenu de
tous les objectifs qui sont les nôtres
en matière de lutte contre la faim je ne
serai pas plus long mais voilà
quelques-uns des résultats et des
initiatives tout ça pour vous dire que
beaucoup de sujets que nous poursuivons
depuis plusieurs années où depuis
plusieurs mois et qui était au coeur de
l'agenda français ont trouvé au moment
de ce g20 un point d'aboutissement et de
concrétisation très important pour nous
est que ce g20 acte une étape importante
dans ce multilatéralisme efficace et des
résultats auquel pour ma part je crois
je vais maintenant répondre à vos
questions la première question sera
posée par sylvie corbet de eddy
bonjour monsieur le président vous avez
souligné l'objectif de maintenir le
réchauffement climatique en dessous de
1,5 degré celsius mais le communiqué
final ne fixe pas de calendrier pour
l'abandon des centrales à charbon au
niveau national et reste assez vague
concernant la neutralité carbone est-ce
que vous n'y voyez pas une contradiction
et dans ces conditions cet objectif de
1,5 degré n'est-il pas simplement
inatteignable alors vous avez totalement
raison que nous n'avons pas tout ce
qu'il faut pour l'obtenir c'est ce que
je disais mais
pareil faut regarder les choses en
dynamique nous partions d'une copie ou
cet objectif ne figurait plus comme un
élément d'accord entre les états membres
et donc la discussion a permis de le
consolider
si nous voulons tenir cet objectif c'est
ce que je vous disais moi même alors oui
il faut tout ce que nous allions vers la
neutralité carbone 2050 met donc en
laque temps les états membres se
remettent dans cette perspective l'union
européenne y est nous l'avons confirmé
en décembre de l'année dernière les
états unis d'amérique le sont ils l'ont
reconquérir mais il y a maintenant un
travail à faire avec les autres grands
émetteurs qui ont
avancé ces derniers temps puisque la
chine a fait beaucoup de progrès que je
ne veux pas sous-estimer elle a dit
qu'elle laisserait en 2060 après elle a
dit qu'elle serait au plus tard en 2060
la russie aussi donc on voit bien que il
ya tout un travail sur cette décade 2050
2060 pour faire avancer ses objectifs
pour y arriver à plus court terme c'est
la sortie du charbon c'est ce que
j'évoquais le grand acquis de ce g20 qui
n'existait pas avant ce g20 c'est
l'arrêt des financements export des
centrales à charbon il y avait trois
grands financeurs export la corée du sud
le japon la chine
et plusieurs autres c'étaient les trois
principaux tout le monde a acté la fin
cette fin d'année de ses financements
c'est une vraie révolution je pense
qu'il faut pas du tout là sous-estimée
c'est une révolution et elle n'était pas
acquise il ya encore quelques mois et
c'est un effort qui est fait par ces
pays et je veux les en remercier et
d'ailleurs il nous faut plutôt nous
maintenant nous concentrer sur le
travail que nous devons faire
vis-à-vis des pays africains car
aujourd'hui trois quarts de la
production électrique africaine dépend
de ce charbon et donc nous devons plutôt
nous mettre en situation devrait
rapidement pour leur offrir d'autres
solutions car le risque que nous courons
en nous consacrant que sur ses grands
objectifs
c'est que certains pays soient forcés
d'aller par exemple vers des centrales à
diesel ce qui serait totalement fou donc
il nous faut plutôt nous tous nous
concentrer pour financer des opérations
ambitieuse pour aller vers du
renouvelable vers du nucléaire vers des
solutions multiples sur le continent
africain sur le mode de ce qu'on fait
avec l'afrique du sud qui d'ailleurs
produit aujourd'hui un mix dans sa
stratégie nucléaire renouvelable donc ça
c'est un acquis du g20 n'était pas avant
maintenant en effet nous devons réussir
à ce que les économies du g20 aille plus
loin sur la part de production de
l'électricité dépendante du charbon dans
leur pays c'est la prochaine étape on ne
l'a pas obtenu la objectivement ça ne
faisait pas partie des résultats qui
étaient d'ailleurs même visée car ça
n'était pas réaliste car nous n'avons
même pas tout à fait en tant
qu'européens ça fait partie des
discussions de green deal il faut rester
lucide mais maintenant il va falloir
mettre au sein du g20 la pression sur ce
sujet
sami 5,6 de ses news
bonjour monsieur le président si nice
fac ci pour canal+ ces news lors de
votre échange avec boris johnson
l'elysée affirme que vous vous est
accordé pour être dans une démarche de
désescalade dans ces tensions qui
agitent nos deux pays sur la question
des licences de pêche or le 10 downing
street à communiquer n'est pas vraiment
sur cette ligne là avez-vous bien décidé
ensemble de prendre des mesures
concrètes et opérationnelles pour calmer
le jeu dc à l'ultimatum qui est fixé à
mardi et concernant justement cette cet
ultimatum le premier ministre
britannique vous demande de levée est ce
que vous êtes prêt à faire ce geste pour
avancer merci mots justes si vous
pouviez me préciser sur quelles lignes
et le 10 downing street
mais parle de poids
ne parle pas de désescalade il parle
justement d'un une position qui pourrait
évoluer si vous retirez cet ultimatum
que vous avez fixé quoi est ce qu'il y a
d'autres questions sur le sujet
relation britannique briques site
peut-être pour être efficace philippe
ricard le monde
bonsoir philippe ricard le monde oui
c'est pour élargir un peu en fait dans
cette affaire de pêche d'abord pour
commencer par ce point de départ est ce
que vous sentez suffisamment soutenue
par les européens par l'union européenne
par les 27 d'une part et d'autre part
comment se fait-il que la france soit la
seule à multiplier les sujets de
contentieux avec le royaume uni 10 10
mois après le brésil est ce que c'est il
ya une relation personnelle dégradé est
ce que c'est lié au simple voisinage ou
à une rivalité ancestrale
et à propos de monsieur johnson avez
vous parlé du sujet au cuss cette
dernière première fois que vous le voyez
depuis de suisse cette annonce du pacte
de défense au détriment de la france est
ce que si si oui que lui avez-vous dit
sinon pourquoi ne lui en avez vous parlé
et s'il ya d'autres questions sur ce
volet 1 je vous rassure notre question
sur le break site
bien
alors
je vais peut-être du coup remettre en
contexte tout ce qui se passe
notre relation avec le royaume uni une
relation qui d'abord à des composantes
bilatérales
certaines de ses composantes ne sont pas
affectés par le brr excite la relation
militaire
elle est régie par des accords
bilatéraux le fait que nous soyons à
lier tous deux au sein de l'organisation
du traité de l'atlantique nord
dans ce cadre là en effet ce qu'on
appelle le l'opération l'accord dit
hocus a manifesté un comportement qui
n'était pas tout à fait celui d'un allié
est celui d'un allié de confiance je lis
acte et je les dis au premier ministre
britannique qui l'a d'ailleurs
parfaitement reconnue je crois qu'il est
difficile de reconnaître le contraire
entre vous et moi oui bien sûr nous en
avons parlé aujourd'hui mais nous avions
eu l'occasion d'échanger
téléphoniquement aussi donc ça c'est le
premier élément qui n'est pas une
initiative de la france qui est
initiative de deux alliés de cette
organisation du traité de l'atlantique
nord de l'australie qui n'est pas une
bonne manière faite à la france de
manière très claire évidente
la deuxième élément qui nous lient au
britannique qui n'est pas lié aux
briques site indépendant libre excite ce
sont les questions migratoires sur ce
sujet nous sommes tous confrontés à des
phénomènes extrêmement préoccupant mais
nous avons tous à la fois un devoir
d'efficacité d'humanité
la france a beaucoup fait ces dernières
années sous le mandat de mon
prédécesseur et le mien pour éviter des
situations terribles
vous savez l'émotion qu'il ya encore
aujourd'hui sur plusieurs situations
qu'il n'ya qu'à les deux personnes qui
sont dans des situations de grande
détresse mais qui ne veulent pas
demander l'asile en france ils veulent
absolument rejoindre terrain britannique
sur ce sujet il y a eu une montée des
tensions qui a fait l'objet de beaucoup
de débats internes au britannique débat
politique avec des pratiques et des
choix que nous ne pouvons pas accepter
qui consiste à refouler en pleine mer
des populations ce qui ne correspond pas
au droit humanitaire international
nous sommes expliqué plusieurs fois sur
ce sujet avec boris johnson nous
coopérons très fortement dans le cadre
des accords qui sont là aussi des nôtres
c'est d'accord du touquet et nous tenons
nos accords avec beaucoup d'exigence
nous souhaitons améliorer la coopération
avec d'autres états européens mais ça
c'est un deuxième sujet bien un
troisième sujet qui sont les sujets de
vie au breakbeat
et ça ça n'est pas bilatérale
ce n'est pas personnel
et je veux ici redire c'est ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure au premier ministre -
rien de personnel la france est un pays
qui a une grande histoire avec le
royaume uni et qui à côté de cette
histoire à une géographie nous sommes le
pays le plus proche
le royaume uni est donc nous voulons
coopérer nous voulons faire des choses
ensemble nous avons ces relations
bilatérales moi même c'est un pays que
je connais bien et que que j'aime comme
je crois le premier ministre d'ailleurs
boris johnson aime la france
nous parlons nos langues réciproque
le peuple britannique de manière
souveraine a décidé de quitter l'union
européenne nous avons pendant quatre ans
discuter d'un accord accords de
retraités accord sur les relations
futures
dix mois après la discussion de cet
accord plusieurs points ne sont toujours
pas appliqués du fait de la partie
britannique nous ne pouvons pas ne rien
dire c'est juste une question de
confiance et de crédibilité
et les deux points aujourd'hui qui sont
en effet qui font l'objet de tensions
sont la pêche et le sujet du protocole
nord-irlandais le premier point est un
point
qui paraît technique qui peut paraître
mineur pour beaucoup de gens enfin on
parle de la vie de femmes et d'hommes
qui dépendent de leur travail qui passe
des jours et des nuits en mer pour
pouvoir nourrir leurs familles et d'un
seul coup parce qu'on ne respecte pas un
accord rendez-vous vous pouvez plus
vivre vous pouvez publier de votre
travail c'est terminé
donc là dessus il faut être sérieux je
ne veux aucune escalade mais il faut
être sérieux cela fait dix mois que nous
travaillons
des licences ont été octroyés je m'en
félicite à certains de nos pêcheurs
beaucoup d'autres licences n'ont pas été
octroyés pour des raisons qui ne sont
toujours pas compris il ya certaines sur
certaines licences des méthodologies qui
ne sont toujours pas fixés le
gouvernement français et l'union
européenne à bon droit ont commencé à
dire si vous restez dans cette approche
il y aura des mesures de attention mon
souhait c'est pas qu'on aille vers des
mesures de rétorsion parce que ça
n'apporte rien aux pêcheurs c'est plutôt
qu'on trouve un accord pour que nos
pêcheurs puissent vivre de leur travail
c'est ce à quoi ils aspirent et donc ce
que nous avons acté avec le premier
ministre john sonne c'est que nous
allions faire une proposition de méthode
qu'est-ce qu'on peut à très court terme
régler comme preuve de bonne volonté
réciproque
et ensuite qu'est ce qu'on va mettre
peut-être plusieurs semaines à régler
pour pouvoir avancer
donc c'est ça ce que j'appelle la
désescalade et c'est ce que nous avons
dit en tête à tête tout à l'heure nous
avons remis aux équipes du président du
premier ministre johnson pardon document
actant de cette méthode
maintenant la balle est dans leur camp
si les britanniques ne font aucun
mouvement de manière évidente les
mesures qui sont prévues à partir du 2
novembre devront se mettre en place
parce que ce sera une fin de non
recevoir la balle est dans le camp des
britanniques nous leur avons remis une
proposition
est donc si les britanniques continuent
à nous d'y réagir comme s'il ne voulait
pas mettre en oeuvre un accord
ce qui a été signé
commencé à bouger je le regretterai mais
nous ne pouvons pas ne pas répondre et
ne pas défendre nos pêcheurs ceci ne
concerne pas que la france les pêcheurs
belges par exemple sur beaucoup de
navires sont très concernés et aussi
beaucoup d'autres pays européens les
danois les allemands les néerlandais etc
d'autres sujets relevant de la pêche
prendront peut-être un peu plus de temps
deuxièmement sur le protocole
nord-irlandais le premier ministre
johnson m'a fait part des difficultés
politiques qui étaient les siennes à
mettre en oeuvre ce qu'il avait tout de
même lui même signé
je respecte cette situation et quand on
parle du protocole nord-irlandais on
parle d'une situation qui est éminemment
inflammable et dangereuse et on parle
d'un sujet
qui je vous le rappelle il ya quelques
décennies est un sujet de guerre ou de
paix sur notre continent
en cette matière c'est la commission
européenne qui négocie
mais j'ai proposé au premier ministre
johnson qui nous fasse une proposition
qui soumettent de manière très concrète
ce qu'il proposait comme amendement
comme évolution pour que nous puissions
avancer donc voilà où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui la discussion était une
discussion franche apaisé exigeante
parce que des accords ont été signés qui
doivent être respectées respectueuse des
contraintes et de la souveraineté de
chacun mais je pense qu'il nous faut
pouvoir avancer parce que beaucoup de
nos compatriotes de part et d'autre du
channel et plus largement en europe nous
attendent mais j'insiste sur un point
quand on parle de la pêche quand on
parle du protocole nord-irlandais ce
n'est pas une question bilatérale c'est
une question entre le royaume uni
et l'union européenne et c'est une
question de respect des accords qui ont
été signés à ce titre la commission
européenne est à nos côtés comme
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des états
européens et nous sommes toujours
solidaire comme la france d'ailleurs a
été toujours solidaire au côté de
l'irlande quand il s'agissait du
protocole nord-irlandais question de
jacques sereys europe 1
m
bonjour monsieur le président pouvez
vous vous levez c'est là qu'est la balle
est dans le camp du royaume uni et c'est
ce que vous dites pourtant c'est ce que
nous disait ce midi boris johnson que la
balle était dans le camp de la france
sans doute parce qu'il parlait du
document que j'évoquais qui lui a été
remis comme je lui avais dit deux heures
après notre rendez-vous
là-bas n'a changé de camp pour ce qui
est du protocole nord-irlandais la balle
est dans le camp des britanniques soyons
clairs parce que là le protocole
nord-irlandais c'est celui qu'il a signé
en décembre dernier
donc l'ultimatum reste d'actualité
jusqu'à mardi je suis cohérent c'est à
dire que je souhaiterais engagé pour
réengager
j'ai fait une proposition qui n'est pas
la totalité de nos demandes mais qui est
de dire donner des gestes à court terme
montrant de réengagement de la
discussion pour qu'on puisse à ce
moment-là reprendre une discussion
apaisé on ne peut pas en rester là le
statu quo n'est pas un réengagement donc
nous nous avons proposé une évolution
progressive qui permettent peut-être
d'avoir des résultats
progressivement ensemble maintenant la
balle est dans le camp des britanniques
j'espère qu'il y aura demain une réponse
positive
je vous propose de coupler les deux
dernières questions va prendre une
question de laurence figuet talamanca d'
antza
allez-y et puis après on prend l'autre
question de makthar allez vous faire
monsieur le président à la fin de ce
sommet est ce qu'on ne peut parler d'un
succès de la présidence italienne et de
la médiation de du président draguer ou
est-ce que sur le climat et sur la date
dont on parlait tout à l'heure de 2050
on aurait pu faire plus je vous pose la
question même en vue de la coop 26 dans
l'italie à la coprésidence avec le
royaume uni merci et puis une question
de magdalena brest acova de nhk
monsieur le président tout à l'heure
vous avez mentionné vos discussions avec
certains de vos partenaires du g20 sur
l'un d'eux l'un d'eux pacifique donc je
voulais savoir qu'elles sont des
avancées dans cet agenda et d'autre part
qu'elle est la rolls du japon dans ce
vaste partenariat que vous souhaitez
développer
alors sur votre première question je
veux vraiment ici redire d'abord mes
remerciements au président matar est là
qui nous a accueilli hier soir et qui
a eu des paroles très fortes en défense
du multilatéralisme
remercié comme je le disais le peuple
romain pour elle la population de rome
pour vraiment
son accueil chaleureux et pour avoir
aussi accepté de supporter toutes les
contraintes qui vont avec un g20 et
enfin et surtout remercier évidemment le
président du conseil mario draghi pour
son travail moi je pense vraiment que ce
g20 est un succès d'abord parce qu'il a
permis d'obtenir des résultats très
concrets sur beaucoup de points qui
était attendu la taxation internationale
des droits de tirage spéciaux le climat
les vaccins ensuite parce qu'on peut
toujours dire oui il fallait avoir mieux
c'est la clarification que j'ai essayé
d'apporter en réponse à votre confrère
pour la première question
néanmoins ça aurait pu être bien pire et
beaucoup de signes on allait dans la
mauvaise direction ces dernières
semaines et ces derniers mois et donc je
pense que ce j 20 est un g20 utile parce
qu'il cristallise une avancée qui nous
permet d'arriver beaucoup plus armés
pacifiquement et beaucoup plus préparés
pour cette coop 26 et que maintenant
nous sommes en situation de faire de
glasgow un succès si nous parachever les
100 milliards de financements du fonds
vert et si nous arrivons à convaincre
encore davantage quelques-uns donc oui
je pense que c'est un succès et c'est
vraiment une étape d'avancée importante
sur ce sujet du climat sur la question
de la dope pacifique j'ai pu l'évoquer
avec plusieurs de mes collègues je
l'avais évoqué avec le premier ministre
japonais téléphone quand nous étions
parler je n'ai pas vu ici puisqu'ils
n'étaient pas physiquement présent mais
représenté par ministre
vous savez depuis que la france a
présenté sa stratégie indo pacifique au
printemps 2010 8 laquelle ensuite a fait
l'objet d'un travail entre européens et
a été si je puis dire traduite ou
augmenter à travers une stratégie indo
pacifique de l'union européenne qui a
été acté en septembre 2021 nous avons
toujours la même vision celle de faire
de participer à une stratégie
géopolitique ou l'inde au pacifique doit
être un espace d'abord de liberté de
mouvement et de respect des
souverainetés et donc d'être une
puissance
coopérative
déquilibre respectueuse des souveraineté
de chacun c'est pourquoi la france qui
est une puissance indo pacifique par
plus d'un millions de compatriotes qui
vivent dans cette zone plus de 8000
soldats déployés et plus plusieurs
opérations chaque année
complexe seul ou en partenariat la
france continuera de jouer ce rôle avec
des partenariats multiples et des
opérations structurantes dans la région
deuxième point nous pensons que l'inde
au pacifique doit être un espace de
commerce libre de déploiement
d'activités et de déploiement de
technologies libres continuant à
promouvoir les valeurs démocratiques
c'est pourquoi nous développons des
partenariats en matière de 5g des
changes de câbles sous marins et autres
avec toutes les puissances de la région
troisièmement
l'inde au pacifique doit être un espace
de
défense de la biodiversité notre agenda
climatique
c'est exactement ce que nous faisons
avec nos territoires mais c'est les
partenariats que nous avons voulu
construire autour de la polynésie
française la nouvelle calédonie mais
également à la réunion et mayotte avec
justement les états voisins et on a tout
particulièrement fait avec les états du
pacifique sud pour réussir à déployer
des stratégies actives de préservation
de restauration de la biodiversité de la
lutte contre les dérèglements
climatiques
cet agenda complet c'est celui que nous
voulons déployer avec tous les
partenaires de la région où sont nos
lignes rouges
nous ne voulons pas en quelque sorte
qu'il y ait de vassalisation de l'un ou
l'autre dans la région et nous ne
voulons pas qu'il y ait de l'autre côté
de confrontation et donc le rôle de la
france dans cette région est d'être là
aussi cette puissance d' équilibre qui
cherchent à construire un agenda
pacifique
cohérente avec notre agenda climatique
et biodiversité est cohérente avec un
agenda de développement économique dans
la région à ce titre les accords que
nous avons avec le japon nous permettent
évidemment de développer un partenariat
tout à fait privilégiée sur beaucoup de
ces points nous l'avons aussi avec
l'inde et nous cherchons à le renforcer
avec singapour et avec l'indonésie nous
avons aussi des discussions et comme
vous le savez une relation
qui est multiple est multifactorielle
avec la chine et même si nous avons des
désaccords de valeur nous souhaitons
aussi pouvoir trouver les équilibres qui
sont nécessaires à la région voilà la
ligne qui est la nôtre sur ce sujet très
bien la conférence de presse est
maintenant terminée je remercie à tous
et on vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée
merci beaucoup mesdames messieurs bon
courage